foreign  I come to bring you home son  opioids were involved in 93 000 deaths  last year  they keep piling up one after another  hey Mike how's it going it was brown I  suppose like the world or like a toilet  difference of perspective I reckon  so how you doing it's still sober that's  what you're asking me right now  [Music]  welcome to the family  [Music]  I love you ruby red  Ruby hey hey come on wake up  um Ruby oh no Ruby  she wanted to be washed in the river  okay Ruby had choices but some of them  choices were made for  foreign  I want you to feel what she felt when  she died  Shelby John suspected in the killing of  a local heroin dealer  if you're fine tell him I just want to  talk  can I help you  if you left your lab you must have told  him something what was it I ain't seen  foreign  God improves what you've been doing  if that wasn't god pushing me to do his  business I don't know what it was  I still got some sin left too  [ __ ]